yeah yeah you're gonna feast on this one conceptuality is something other than itself
there's been a change in the image of thought, that's what it is, that's what it is, that's what
it is, the internal structure of but as soon as an utterance slips from the mouth it's divorced
from the subject i gave them an assignment this week this is i mean we're in our third week or
whatever but i created an in-class exercise uh, in other words, we met asynchronous asynchronously
and i was so exposed like last week i said let me be clear about what's happening next week and i
said it very very clearly and then on the weekend i sent out an email very clearly delineating what
they were supposed to do and what they had to submit by when and where like everything and i got five
emails uh out of uh 32 students. Well, in the one section, five emails saying either like i didn't
really understand the instructions are we meeting in class today what you know like and the only thing
that the five people had in common is they were all men oh yeah that's been my that's my experience
across the board is only men had those kinds of problems but but it's like what is wrong with you
right like what what is like something is wrong at a at a basic level it's just like
did they know how to tie their shoes really like i mean i mean i get that they didn't listen or
didn't pay attention but i sent a freaking email in which i laid it all out and then one guy was like
i read through the email and i couldn't understand i didn't see what chapter we were supposed to read
and i look back at my email and i'm like chapter 19 joanna bork what it means to be human like
yeah i mean they struggle is it mostly what year are they all over the place it's all over the place
yeah okay yeah i mean i find that a lot of freshmen have that problem they just seem overwhelmed just
with the idea of completing assignments in general so even if even if they're kind of trying to be on top
of their work they're constantly asking me questions right after i told them what they had to do
you know i'm pretty patient anxiety levels are definitely up especially for first year students
who like spent their last two years in high school i get that i'm sympathetic i mean i'm sympathetic to
the anxiety stuff i i mean i am but in a situation like this where it's we're not talking about
difficult stuff we're not talking you know this is like super bad like read page 10 to 20
direction and they and they go like i don't even know what the assignment was
and you're like and you're like eyes listening yeah do you see me but what are you supposed to do
what do you do in those circumstances where i'm just like i mean i honestly like i sent responses to
them like what the fuck is wrong with you i mean that's what i said
like something is clearly wrong with you yeah like you should see someone and you should see someone
and it's not me yeah yeah i am not the right kind of expert for the problems that you have
right right you're not gonna learn anything in this class like
there's no if you can't handle that stuff like how to tie your shoes there's no point in you taking
this class that almost doesn't deserve a reply like you could just forward the email back to us
yeah i didn't reply to some of them i was just like it's like the ones who said like hey are we
meeting for class today i'm in the i'm in the waiting area and i was like well then i hope you
stayed there for an hour and 15 minutes like yeah i just yeah all guys all guys like and i
absolutely am going to say this to them like i am i'm gonna tell them this like i got 32 of you
five of you send me emails not understanding and they're all men they're all white men too
i mean like let's say that in 15 20 years of teaching there's something like that has happened
to me a hundred times my guess is that a minimum of 95 of them have been white men i am sympathetic
to the anxiety level i'm sympathetic to the bad student thing but this is really really like
you know take your finger and touch it to your head and they'll be like yeah and they're like wait
yeah you know i don't think i can do that or i don't even know what you're asking us to do
yeah or i don't care to take the time i don't think that this is important enough
for me to devote enough brain cells to even trying to figure it out right right like but
truthfully how many brain cells does this take
like i mean that's the that's the the height of the arrogance like not even worth the two
like you think you'd be embarrassed to send that email out after you'd already i mean like just
just just ignore it and fail the assignment or something yeah just just just eat it, you know
so, uh, well, so, all right, if we're, if we actually start the podcast, we got to start by saying so.
This is a little intro, yeah. Nathaniel, you're good at this. Do this, do the intro, yeah.
So we are back with season four of Thinking With, and we are focusing on The Gay Science
by Friedrich Nietzsche, uh, this time around. We're gonna, uh, unlike the last season where we kind of
jumped around a lot of Derrida's essays, we're gonna focus the entire season on The Gay Science, so our
first episode is just on the uh preface to the second edition, which Nietzsche wrote, I think, four
years after the publication of this book in 1886. And, um, the uh, the series of uh poetry that he added
to uh, that the book as well, called Joke, Cunning, and Revenge: Prelude in German Rhymes. And I, I don't
I mean, John, I know this has been a cornerstone book in your life for a very long time. It's one
that's, I've read multiple times. Nate, I, I know that you've read it in the past. I don't know how sort
of intimate it is in your life, but I think for this project that we've, we've had, you know, we've had
we've, we've engaged things that was very new to us and that we've never read before, and we've engaged
some things that we knew pretty well, and I think The Gay Science is going to give us a very particular
challenge in that I think for John especially it's sort of like just etched into your soul.
Sometimes, and so figuring out what to do with this thing, how to talk about it, how to differentiate it
from yourself if that's even, like, what even if that's even a valuable thing, um, to do, and then the
other thing is because it's so aphoristic, you know, I think one of the sort of explicit questions that
we're going to have over and over again, given our continuing concern with pedagogy, is how would we
even approach teaching this thing in the class? I've never taught it in a class, Nate. I don't think
you've taught it, John, I know you have, but I know it's always a sort of open-ended question for you, so
I think those are some of the the challenges that we're going to have addressing this book. What do
you do with it? I actually don't know if I've ever read this. Um, obviously I've read, I've read plenty
of Nietzsche, so the the preface felt familiar, you know, in a way, but I don't recall necessarily reading past
the preface or any of book one, book two. I don't think you taught The Gay Science in your Nietzsche class
with us, John, when when I took that, so that probably would have been the only time that I would have read
it. So this is kind of a fresh, a fresh book for me. Yeah, I mean, I I've taught, well, I mean just chunks of
like book three, um, that sort of the, I think it's book three that begins with the Buddha's died and
God, the first proclamation of God is dead, and the shadows of God, and then the next uh several, like
eight or so sections. Um, and and yeah, I mean it's, but but I mean first I should say like what Nathaniel
said is right, like this is, I mean this isn't like uh, this isn't a book that people talk about from
Nietzsche scholarship. Like when when you read anything in Nietzsche scholarship they will talk about obviously
Genealogy of Morals, yeah, it gets tons of coverage, Zarathustra gets coverage, a lot of stuff from Will
to Power, the notebooks stuff uh gets coverage, Twilight, like Ecce Homo, this and I have to say like even still
just going back through this, like this is the single most important book in my life, like, and and has been
just because I came across it super early on when I knew nothing of Nietzsche and just started reading it and
it, you know, I mean etched in my soul is sort of right. It's like, I mean I, it's hard for me to think
about talking about this just because I've been reading it for, you know, literally 40, 40 years, right?
Since you were what, 15, 16? 16, 16 years old. You know, when I picked it up in a bargain bin at, you know,
because it was on sale for 99 cents and I had just gotten paid from my summer job and I had somehow come
across the name Nietzsche and just pick this, pick this one up, and uh, and I've literally had that copy and reading
that copy ever since then, um, until now. So because at your guys' behest I got another because my other copies
down is down in South Carolina, so I got a new copy, a fresh one without all of my years of notes, and it's like
it feels strange to not see like marks from the 80s and the 90s and the 00s, like just annotations and
stuff. It's like, wow, this is just, this one's just fresh, and the, you know, I'm even bugged because
the actual alignment of the text on the page is not exactly like it was in the other edition.
Like foolish things like that, I'm like this isn't the right book, you know. Um, but yeah, and it's been
a problem. It's it's not even just how to teach it, it's also just how to talk about it, right? Like it's
like how to even engage with it. I mean like I said, it's something that I've been reading
incessantly, but I, I never, and it's it's, you know, I've told you guys what I have. Like you go through
those funky, like funky phases in your life, and for me there are certain books like uh, to lose his
Nietzsche's book is one of them, Thousand Plateaus, but this one is the kind of has been the constant
one for 30 years of just like this sense of exuberant joy, um, linked to, you know, the kind of
eviscerating thinking that Nietzsche, uh, uh, that characterizes Nietzsche, and but the the sense of joy
and irreverence, um, for me this is this is the book and it's it continues to surprise me that people don't
talk about The Gay Science being this extraordinary work of of philosophy, you know, so do you come back
to this book like when you're feeling a certain way or just kind of consistently over the years
like you'll just pick it up every year? Yeah, I'll just pick it up. Okay. I mean it was for many many
years it was my bathroom book, meaning I would just like every day I'm just gonna pick it up and read
an aphorism or two or what you know, um, and and that's mostly how I read it then. It was never like
well I'm gonna sit down and spend some time reading The Gay Science. It was just like every day it was
like my my daily uh affirmation, right? Like, I mean, that's that's sort of how I used it, and I mean that
for like 20 years. That was every every single day. So I mean I read this book, I don't know however many
times, 10, 12 times. I I never read it front to back; I would just like wherever I was I would read the
next few pages or whatever, but I know I have never attempted to write about it, and um, and I don't even
know it's one of those things like I don't even know how it's a book, right? There's this the Kaufman
quote I have the I'm doing the Kaufman one but the Kaufman quote on the backs like this book mirrors
all of Nietzsche's thought and could be related in hundreds of ways to his other books, his notes, and
his letters and yet it is complete in itself for it is a work of art, and I'm like that that last part I
just go I complete and I don't even know what that means, like I don't know what it would mean
to write about this as something that's complete in itself, um. I mean, it's it strikes me as everything
that he's doing in here just even in terms of the structural stuff, um, of like beginning with these
little pithy uh poems, um, and then moving into aphorisms on certain, you know, and and it changes
because, you know, he added book four much much later, um, and you know, the the kind of tone or tenor of the
is seems to me clearly to be set up to be like not a book, like in the sense of a unit unified
entity, um, so it's just weird when I read that Kaufman version of like, you know, it is complete
in itself, and it's like I I don't think that's what's going on almost against the whole philosophical
spirit that's that's laid out and especially in the preface, like sort of against that metaphysical
notion of unity or wholeness, right? I mean, he kind of lays it out. So do you think that is structurally
you think that was on purpose that he made it a little more dispersed and kind of disunified
I mean this is a choice. It's definitely it's definitely I mean in terms of the structure of
the thing, like to have the songs in the on the front end and then to have the uh series of longer poems
uh appendix and songs, you know, on the back end, um, everything in between reads like Nietzsche's
aphoristic stuff, like in not tone not tonally like Beyond Good and Evil. That's where to me what's
distinctive about this is the kind of joyful, right, quality, you know, it really is, and uh, as opposed to
Beyond Good and Evil, which is like more relentlessly warlike or something, or even Twilight of the Idols
and those things, but um, and that's what I love. That's the whole appeal is the tone of this, but
structurally, you know, the like books one through four look just like his other kind of aphoristic works
um, but the you know, the weird rhymes and the right it's also like the little pithy poems they're very
bad, right? Like, I mean, as poems, you know, even in German and they're playfully bad, right? Like, I mean, he
says this right exactly exactly they're sing-songy, right, and he but I mean he says that like he kind
of makes fun of of that quality but so he's very clearly doing things with the form of a book, right?
like obviously for some purpose uh, and I think we'll get to some of that in terms of the the preface but um
speaking of that Kaufman quote about the um, the sort of the completeness of itself and and Nate
you said like the spirit of the book seems to be against it especially in the preface and this is
you know, in section two of the the preface where he's talking about philosophy as a kind of a symptom
or an expression of a kind of bodily health or or sickness and he's talking about these various
sicknesses is like look when you see a philosophy that does this kind of thing then start questioning
or or probing for the like for sickness and this is um sort of like maybe halfway through the second
section uh I'll start with every philosophy that ranks peace above war every ethic with a negative
definition of happiness every metaphysics and physics that knows some finale a final state of
some sort every predominantly aesthetic or religious craving uh some apart beyond out uh outside above
permits the question whether it was not illness that inspired the philosopher and that's you know i
mean in some ways if there's a form to this book it is definitely one that tries to trouble or
um uh agitate that notion of of completeness or wholeness for that for the sake of inducing some kind of
tone some approach some fröhliche, which i mean look that's part and part of the issue in terms of its
reception in english is obviously the meaning of the word gay has changed in the last 60 years, right? Like the
predominant association is different than it was so i've seen the trend the translation of joyful wisdom, which i like
better. Um, but whatever gay science that's the that's the name of it so like um and those aren't those are
perfectly good words if they're heard in a certain register but you know well didn't Kaufman argue for
gay over joyful in the in his little translator's introduction because of how because of like how
transgressive that word is compared to joyful so he wanted to like keep that as opposed to the yeah but
that was also 60 years ago like it's just a different it has a different right like today if you hear the
word gay you don't think joyful at all right like it just doesn't have that association anymore you know
but i think it's for that exact i mean it does have that association i mean especially sort of like the
way it's performed to say like pride right but you're right like the term gay has sort of
shifted from that notion of joyfulness even on like uh sexual queerness to like an identity category
it's one of the reasons why it's one of the reasons i like the the title the translation
re remaining the gay science just as a way of sort of having the possibility or the the um
the possibility of connecting or sort of continuing to effuse that sense of joyfulness or um uh into the
like into the identity category of gayness itself it's like like this is sort of a way of like
you know don't forget where this came from don't you know like be careful about letting this thing
solidify too much like you know the origins here the the genesis of gay as a gay as an identity
category is joyfulness right well in that sense you wouldn't need the word queer because it seems to me
you know because queer sort of emerges it seems like or maybe it just gets mobilized say in
in distinction from the identity category like right except for in some weird alchemy queer has
which is this thing that's supposed to agitate the identity category has become its own identity category
anything can be nominalized right yeah
even though like you were saying John the tone is different like there is way more joy um and sort
of exuberance exuberance exhilaration whatever um but you still get him sort of remaining with that
critical eye towards all kinds of different philosophies and where they come from and what
tendencies emerge from them you know uh i really like that i mean it's and that if you continue that the
quote that Nathaniel was reading if you continue just a couple of you know sentences on that's the one
the place that gets quoted a lot from there is right after that where and i've often asked myself
whether taking a larger view philosophy is not merely has not been merely an interpretation of the body
and a misunderstanding of the body right philosophy is just an interpretation of the body or the way that
we would say would be an expression of a way of life right like that would be the more common that's
just like what it means to philosophize is an expression of a certain disposition uh of of the body
now the body here not simply as this fundamental material thing but as you know a conjunction of
different forces um but that's the i mean that moment of like that's what philosophy is like philosophy
is an expression so you know you find the philosophies that hook for you or that help you become what you
will have been um not because they're true and that that that question is just like i mean it's
certainly for Nietzsche you're like the question of which philosophy is true is like it's not really
ridiculous question yeah i mean just it just misses the whole gambit or rather that question is one
gambit but he yeah he explicitly like turns he's like philosophy we've been mistaken to think that
philosophy is the pursuit for truth and in fact that pursuit for truth has led to a like a whole series of
of problems uh this is that in the that's in the last section um section four when he's talking about
the Egyptian cults of the the veiled god the veiled god of truth and he this is the second time i mean
he does this in Beyond Good and Evil but he um uh likens truth to a woman this is like in the penultimate
paragraph perhaps truth is a woman who has grounds for not showing her grounds perhaps her name is to speak
Greek Baubo, which i love that footnote like to like Baubo who like the after after Demeter is
Loses her, her daughter, Persephone, to Hades and has been mourning her and baobo to cheer her up
lifts up her skirts to expose herself and he's like, that's fucking funny, i can laugh again
but here he's praising the veiledness of of life and the like, a certain kind of modesty of thinking
should prevent us from even wanting to see everything naked, even if it were possible, but
i mean it's that's it to me that's a big point, you know, there, like on the previous page in the same
section um there are a few things we know too well, we knowing ones, oh, how we now learn to for
learn to forget, well, and to be good at not knowing. uh and i mean i that's to me a very very interesting
i mean i i remember there's several things in this press, preface, when i reread them, and i
thought of the many times that i've read them previously, and it's like i always thought that
they were just like i don't know clever turns of phrase, like you know, it's easy to read those just
like aha we should get good at not knowing, and you're like yeah that seems cool in the kind of
bumper stickery way, um slow, like it's mysterious but it's meant to be mysterious, and but now i'm like
i read it differently, i read it as a very precise injunction. yeah you know yeah that that there actually
is uh in the pursuit of truth, what i mean whatever term you want to use, that there is a significant value
to the way you pursue and to to that issue of like not knowing as as part of your itinerary and not as
just like the not as a limit point on the horizon that you haven't gotten to yet but as a constitutive
and enabling element, right, like and i read those things it's like wow that's that's incredibly
like insightful and not just a pithy maxim, you know? right well he he emphasizes that mutability
of philosophy as kind of a constitutive component, so you're for him philosophy is the shifting of
coordinates. it is the kind of transfiguring of your own value system of motivations. it's that
constant sort of searching and pressing and and moving forward into the future rather than uh sort of
cementing some sort of final grounds or truths as as we were saying, um i like what she says at the
beginning of of the section three if i if i were to put in a very delusian rendering is there's there's
like there are as many philosophies as there are healths kinds of healths. yeah he's like look this is
actually a limitation of those with a burly substantial health is that they is like their their philosophy is
too unchanging. it's too they're not able to sort of go through these transformations in virtue of a kind
of health and this is i mean this is what he talks about his own period of sickness, the the few years
before writing this book, and he talks about his sickness as its own kind of health, as allowing him
to do philosophy differently, to philosophize differently, right, but he talks about that process, that that that
pain, that suffering, that the transformation of one's health, you know, he he says, and this is sort of
halfway through section three, and i think this is speaking to what both of you were just talking
about. i doubt that such pain makes us better but i know that it makes us deeper whether we learn to
pit our pride our scorn our willpower against it like the savage who however badly tormented repays
his tormentor with the malice of his time or whether we withdraw before pain into the oriental nothingness
called nirvana, into mute rigid death self-surrender self-forgetting self-extinction. and here's the
important part: one emerges from such dangerous exercises and self-mastery as a different person
with a few more question marks, above all with the will henceforth to question further more deeply severely
harshly evilly and quietly that one has been previous, that then one has previously questioned
and i think that that precise art of not knowing, that precise capacity of not knowing not as some
sort of like iconoclastic like punch you in the face philosophy you're after truth what i'm in after
it's like no this is actually as you said john constituatively part of there's an artistry of not knowing
let me give an example of this is something that that occurred last week on facebook with um
a column written the day after Serena retired that basically says like look Serena was great at
everything but let's like slow down on the hagiography like there's she was a problematic figure
in lots of ways and he posted this thing saying and he framed it by saying this is one of the more
thoughtful things that i've read on Serena so you can imagine the blowback right it was just it was just
like this like oh my god this is so it's so racist it's so sexist like i mean and and really like
incredibly vitriolic and angry uh responses to the column to his posting it to whatever whatever
and um and he was like you know he was sort of trying to defend the various points in in in ways and his
responses to people's responses and i posted a thing and i just and i didn't i mean i was just being my
typical like smart ass self you know i just posted like this makes me think of kairos because like look
here was my response to it there may actually be some value in the points that the essay makes
but the day after her final match right you're being an asshole like there's no other way to me
there's no other way of understanding it like and and here's what that means it's not that
these are valid points at some times but not at other you know these are valid points we just have
to wait for the moment to arrive that would be the kairos understanding right like there are different
qualitative dimensions of time where this this thinking will be possible and available and i kind
of wanted to say something or it made me think something a little bit different than that which
is that the moment is infused in the points which is to say like it's not simply a a contextual
surrounding of the argument right it's not like there's the argument and if you had made it later it
would have been more acceptable or if you made it earlier it would have been more acceptable but at this
time you're being a dick right and because that that presumes the separability of the content of the
thing from the circumstances of its emergence and so as i started thinking about it i was like no no
no this is like there's so much that's wrong with this in this sense and so much that's oblivious
right and will willfully oblivious i mean look the only reason you write that is because people are
paying attention to Serena Williams right so it's well and even if it's not cynical it's like well
i'm thinking about this because people are thinking about this so i have have something to say um so it
is it's it is constituted by that moment it's not something that you realistically could write
in a few weeks or a few months when things have because it's just not part of that moment anymore
and so it was just this interesting way that i started thinking like the problem with the usual
way of thinking of kairos is we think of like you know the argument didn't work at this time but it
might have been acceptable at another time and i was like i actually think they're more deeply infused
and not as separable or extricable as that and that's i think sort of what you know the kind of
content of one's philosophy is constitutively infused by the way of life right it's not just something that
happens you know you don't happen to get the Gay Science from Nietzsche you could have gotten it from
somebody else like no this is this is it like this is
these circumstances and this implication is what produces this kind of thing
because that would produce a separability between i mean that would be that the sort of transcendent
claim like here are these ideas that are available and nature just so happened to get to them which
means that anyone else could have gotten it like no right this spirit at this time and these like in
this orientation i mean it is singular in that way that's how i've always understood i've always read
because you know he has tons of personal stuff especially like in this preface but also Ecce Homo
and stuff like that where he's like these are the conditions of my life you know and i've and
i've always been like okay so that's a typical you know like author right authors always often not
thomas pinchon but like they often want to talk about like well what were the circumstances when
you came up with this thought or what are the circuit you know what i mean like it's that biographical
desire to links it and i always kind of read it that way but i think it's not that at all like it's
for him it's like no this is the circumstances of life out of which this kind of thing emerge they are
aren't they are uh translatable but they're not identically translate like there are other ways
like one can have interventions into this from other kinds of life um but there's just a lot of
people who are not going to get it's just not going to resonate it's not going to make sense it's not
going to click and it's not going to hook makes that claim a lot you know right right like you know
what fault is it of mine if you don't like if you don't like my fruit and and those sorts of things
yeah so the role of the biographical here i think is is pretty interesting but here we have to think
about subjective i'm sorry singularity is not something that is subjective it is not the the
personal biography or the the subjectivity of Nietzsche here and you know i i'm looking actually at one
of the rhymes and then the very beginning of the first section of the preface so here's the 23rd rhyme
called interpretation if i read me then i'd read into me i can't construe myself objectively but he
who climbs consuming his own might bears with me bears with him unto the brighter light and then the
very first couple of lines of the preface this book might need more than one preface and in the end
There would still be room for doubting whether someone who has not experienced something similar
could by means of prefaces be brought closer to the experiences of this book. It seems to be written
in the language of the winds that bring a thaw, it contains high spirits, unrest, contradiction, and April
weather, so that one is constantly reminded of winter's nearness as well as the triumph over winter that is
coming must come. Perhaps has already come, and it's the one word that I want to draw attention to is the
the second word of that second sentence seems it seems to be written in this language, and it's like
I mean Nietzsche's writing this preface four years after he published the first book, he's coming back
and the that sort of subjective reflection on the thing will be like here's what I was trying to say
here's what I'm clarifying here's because this book is an extension of me in some ways like no he's
treating himself at a certain distance. It's him and it's not him at the same time. He's sort of
approaching this thing that's ostensibly his as a phenomenon that is both intimately intertwined with
him and also not him yeah it's a symptom of yeah a way of life you know and that's why it's so cool
that's where like you know the beginning of number two but let us leave here Nietzsche what is it to
us that here Nietzsche has become what I can right and and he moves into the typology like this sort of
typological uh conversation like there are certain types that think in certain ways et cetera et cetera so
like that the function I mean I think it's it's it's worth thinking in terms of biography I mean
Derrida obviously does stuff with this the autobiography stuff on Nietzsche like the um that Nietzsche is
obviously doing something with biograph you know like the practice of biography here and I think that you're
quite right he's like it's not that I'm the origin of of the work uh it's that I'm a symptom as is the
work right like I am a symptom of this constellation and these things are symptoms and constellations
like that's all we're that's all we're trafficking in here but you do you do I mean I feel like there
is something there with the distance from the previous version of himself where he kind of can
gain at least some sort of critical reflection of the previous version like I remember I might have
mentioned this a while back but like when I was writing my comprehensive exams and kind of starting the
dissertation I was full of angst and uncertainty and that manifested almost in just like sort of
vicious takedowns of a lot of people in the field and I remember at the time thinking like there was no
other way I could have written that at the because that's what was sort of motivating me at that moment
but now looking back it's like there's you can read that symptom all throughout those comps
right and you just see the anger on the page and you think of this kind of writing like research
based writing is like objective or or like right but it's really it is driven even the most sort of
abstract philosophical writing is driven by sort of uh emotional temperament in some way
misinterpretation of the body right like
and I think you guys are right like it's so funny you both just said this but the one
theme or through line that I tuned into with the preface and all of the stuff is the question of
distance and a kind of desire for a critical distance but sometimes that distance is too
far or too close or one has to shrink the distance sometime but like it's it's not simply clear that one
needs distance or exactly what distance means uh in this case because it seems like it goes back and
forth like I feel like I'd have to do work to kind of parse parse that out but there are like four or
five of the poems where the issue of distance like from a height or from the from the surface or from
below or from the surfaces that that that's sort of you know that geographical you know uh um
version of where where does thinking happen best it's not below it's not above it's you know in the
fields what he talks about why it's not the Greeks here that he says but the um what's the Greeks at
the end of the preface right that's that's the other famous quote those Greeks were superficial out
of profundity and it's not again that that's one again that's where to me I really used to read that
as a pithy maxim like the Greeks were superficial out of profundity you see how that's just like oh
yeah and I never really I never lived with that thought because it just seemed like a clever chiasmus
you know yeah um but now I read it and I'm like he's making a point here yeah like there's a real
intervention there that that's easily missed just because it's pithy and that's assuming that you're
positively inclined towards the pithy you know so it's easy not to get that like oh there are different
types of superficiality uh there are there's a superficiality of a kind of obliviousness and
there's a superficiality of in of depth and intensity that is a different kind of superficiality, you know
well and the distinction between depth and superficiality it's not just a a value binary or
one's good, one's worse, you know i mean in the the one that i i quoted a little bit earlier
um you know i doubt that such pain makes us better but i know that it makes us deeper and i think of
the genealogy of morals and of morality and thinking about bad it is yeah i mean like it is a resentment
reactive force that provides depth and it comes with a whole series of problems of a resentment but it's also
allows for cunning and cleverness and and depth of feeling but then there's also a profounded like
there's a there's a profundity of of the superficial as well
i mean i feel like we've run through basically what he's saying in pretty complex terms i'm wondering
if we can get almost a simple breakdown of what he means by that quote that you read earlier, John, that the
greeks are superficial out of profundity. I mean i feel like i have an idea based on the previous
exposition that the greeks were sort of not necessarily uh thrown into representation in the
same way that more modern human beings are and that they sort of are i i don't really know how
to articulate it like what what does that mean that they are superficial but with sort of a positive
surveillance on that term like i find it difficult i mean the way that i i mean there's several ways of
beginning to answer that one of one of which is when you think of the dionysian apollonian distinction
that he made early in his first book in the birth of tragedy like this is the realm of apollo like this is
you know and you know it's easy to read that book is like dionysus is the good guy and apollo is the bad guy
but that's way i mean in the later work dionysus comes to stand for the amalgam of what was then
dionysus and apollo but in this case it's like no to believe in that stuff is real right like to that
that there is um that a commitment at least to me my sense is that this is not a superficial they're
different so different kinds of superficiality one is just like
oh a kind of obliviousness to the idea that anything's even questioned the vapidness
right like it's like well you know of course stuff is and then to go through the questioning
and then get to the point where you're like and this is all there is and this is and this the
surfaces the tones the words the concepts that we have that's the whole gambit there isn't something
there isn't some alternative deeper meaning right and so it's a second type of surface or a second
type of superficiality that requires a very kind of hegelia you know i mean you could certainly say
it in those terms like you've got to go through the bridge of moves to get to the point where surface
looks different than it did or to live surfacely is a different way of living it's still services
because what else what else is there going to be but to sort of learn to
not just accept or endure the fact that everything is constructed or whatever else but to love it to
be like that's that's the most amazing thing ever like look at this play of forms and words and
concepts you know well i mean i think the other way of articulating that in the language of the
problematic that he uses in the um the birth of tragedy is sort of like he turns to the wisdom of
silenus which is you know like after someone is chasing around silenus and finally catches
him it's like you have to now tell me a truth and and i think it's like what is the best thing for
man to do and she thinks that's hilarious question and responses the best thing would be
that you were never born but the next best thing was that you would die as soon as possible
die fast like you already missed out on the never being born part so i would just off yourself
really quick and i mean like sort of as an encapsulation of the what later becomes that
existential question it's like life is suffering why live what's your response to the suffering
of life and in nietzsche finds in the greeks this profound response to the suffering of life
make a world of images construct the world of images the apollonian the the olympian the entire
mythology here is an entire life world to live in imagine i mean you know it's not out of some
stupidity that that the greeks believe that they could walk in the forest and a centaur might pop
out or the nymphs are in the trees that's motherfucking awesome and right and not and also not like a
proto-religious naivete either but like an intense well or rather just say it this way a just different
way of living than we're capable of like we can't believe in nymphs in forest nymphs right like we're just
too old for that we do too you know history of the enlightenment and science and all like we can't
believe that like we can tell ourselves these stories all the time but we can't believe that
we're just not capable of it in ways that they were in fact capable of that profound superficiality
but what we can the surfaces the the superficiality that we can and do all the time by our depths and
and hidden causes and material underpinnings and truth and and like all of these sort of like
binaries that structure our life world would i think as John was saying before just different
configurations of the surface like different configurations to the suffering of life how do
we do it well we make this distinction between surface and depth and like we try to discount the
importance of the surface and the sort of the ephemerality of it and then try to establish
what we call underpinnings to it to make it regular regularized you know at the end of the right uh
truth and lying in the non-moral sense you know there's the he's like the Greek response is more like
the intuitive person we're more stoic like we create a world of surfaces wherein we can predict the
patterns of thunderstorms so we can make sure we don't get rained on when we see the rain clouds coming our way
right so i feel i feel like in at least in an abstract sense like there's an insistence for
Nietzsche and probably also for Deleuze like you have to kind of multiply and add on to what we already
have um whereas for Heidegger there's kind of like at least in cases there's a there's an insistence on
subtracting you could with this with this kind of a description of the Greeks there could be the claim that
like we need to go back to a pre-metaphysical right that's not what Nietzsche is saying that's
more Heideggerian for sure that's what i'm saying like Heidegger's like we need to subtract the
complexity of life and get back to a sort of proto or whatever like pre-metaphysical pre-depth model
thinking uh way of living but for Nietzsche and for Deleuze it's more about experimentation and sort of
pushing forward like going for yeah going for intensification i mean we have to be careful about
like whether it's addition or subtraction or multiply because all of those things have all kinds of
problems but it's an intensification like it's not a question of like hey let's stop with this
resentment thing and let's go with the affirmation thing it's like no you got to push figure out the
intensities with which one can experiment on negation right like negation isn't just one thing right so
it's not like let's have done with negation and let's go to the realm of right of affirming stuff you
know that that's a pretty key difference though in terms of that approach because there is nostalgia
here obviously like it's like wow the Greeks were really they were able to do something amazing but
it's different from the Heidegger like we i wish we could actually go back there we should cultivate a
way of reaching that exact method and and way of life i don't i i feel like Nietzsche's resisting that
nostalgia in a way that i think is important um and it's a lot different it can be it can it certainly
can be read very Hegelian just like the birth of tragedy i mean this is one of the things that
appealed to me early on about Nietzsche prior to my familiarity with Hegel is that like he says you
know there's the the the tragic world of the Greeks was ended um by Socrates by rationality right like
the that that theory intervenes um and but what he calls for in that book explicitly after the whole
Wagner stuff is not a return to the pre-socratic version it's it's a singing Socrates a dancing
Socrates right like in other words a kind of conjunction taking Socrates and making thinking
dance and so a kind of you could say auf haben i mean i think that there are reasons not to say
for that book i think but um but nevertheless it's like smells offensively Hegelian right uh but
nevertheless it's like no no it's not a question of getting back to the thing for exactly the reasons
i was just saying in terms of the Serena Williams quote it's like this is this is not something that
works in this other environment like this is these are the conditions now and now you you you experiment
with those things and see what those are capable of like because that's all that you can do and
that requires an investment and a kind of belief in the world of forms and concepts and shapes and
the stuff around it you gotta like okay this is this is where we are right i mean this is another
this is another facebook exchange i have but uh someone posted about like you know given all of
the climate change and political unrest of like how does one continue uh fighting when you have a pretty
good idea that you're like you're not you're not gonna win and it's like win like what win i mean
it's and i understand the way i understand the way of thinking but for me it's like it's never been about
winning like i i don't even understand in fact i'm very much need and this is what i posted on this
Thing is like I'm very much in a chain and this is like the only fights worth fighting are the ones
where you're certain you're going to lose like in other words it's not a it's not a question of
winning it's about the agon itself right it's about the the work or the fight or whatever
terminology you want to use to configure because that's all that that's all that it is so i mean
maybe that's too sisyphean i guess but it's it's not even sisyphus because it's not the same rock
like what i found interesting about uh Camus's take on sisyphus is it's a different rock every time and that's
pretty awesome that you know like you might like get the rock up there it would suck if you got the
rock and it stayed up there or if you there was no precipice to the mountain it was just like some
kind of progressivism where you have this unending doesn't like you get to the rock and then it gets
to a tipping point and that's a different fucking rock the different you too
sort of housed in this conversation i think is is an interesting response or at least a way into
thinking that sort of initial problem that we had about what to do with this book how do we orient
ourselves to this book how do we orient students to this book in the classroom and one of the values
of sort of it being destabilized as a book as a unity uh in that very sort of Thousand Plateausy kind of
way is that it makes it very difficult to imagine it along those depth models where it has some kind
of point or information within it that you're going to sort of lead your students through and then and
then get it resists thinking about it that way and therefore it draws attention to the way that wine
navigates oneself with within it and it's not i guess it shouldn't be really shocking that so many of
uh what so much of what we've already talked about and so much of what is in the preface and in the
prelude has to do with following and depths and dis and surfaces and distances and closeness and you
know i was i've been looking for this uh rhyme since we started because i actually really think
that speaks to you know the problem that John has of this book being etched in his soul and for him
what do you do with this so this is number 25 a request i know another person's thought and who i
am i know that not my vision is too close to me i am not what i saw and see i'd use myself more
perfectly if i could move away from me yet not so distance as not so distant as my foe my closest friends
too far too far off no give me instead the middle ground do you surmise what i propound
i can't get away from the sing-songyness of reading those out loud but like this question of of
distance and closeness is this is it's come up a multitude of times and it's at least the second time
in in what i read about the value of the middle ground you know don't go to the tights don't go to the
the depths find find the middle and every time i read it it smacks very sort of Aristotelian to me
that sort of the the golden mean you know finding like in the in the phrenesis section of of the
Nicomachean Ethics or it's like you know the virtue is always about sort of like navigating or finding
the right middle between the ever-changing but yet right middle between uh vices of um uh extreme and
vices of of um not having enough of the thing but i don't think that he is no talking about the middle
in the same kind of way and that's something that i'd like to sort of sit on and think about
this medium that he's talking about because i'm pretty sure it's not Aristotelian think of the
the middle and to lose at the end of the rhizome chapter right like that it goes back and forth but
not between things but a transversal movement sweeping one in the other with the way like it's an
it's an early attempt to think a middle that's not between two things uh that's not localizable so what
the middle means there is not a median between a located between two quasi identities again i feel like
it's this it's you know you're talking about a kind of relation of indiscernible i mean that's how
i always go in those directions which is it's precisely the not knowing where you are that's
relevant about his discussion of the middle not because um it's between um but because it's
unlo it's unlocatable of course the middle it can be locatable right like uh and we can think of it
it is located if you have the extremes right but what he's after and i i mean i do take this that's
where i said like those are the kinds of things that i used to always read as pithy maxims like
pithy clever phrasings and i'm like i actually think that there's a lot uh going on there and one of
it so i mean we can like we'll keep this keep the middle thing sitting there but this is this is one of
of them for me uh that is kind of nagging at me a little bit is how do you treat a book like this
um as you said where it's not just like go in and extract a content an idea like here's the here's
The money idea from each or whatever, um, and not simply these days call it art, right? Like because and
that's the move that he makes. He's like, there's it's he makes a move like it's got it thinking is more
artistic, uh, and we got to consider it, uh, more artistic but I don't want to, that to me just
sort of shunts it into a different realm, right? Like it's just like, okay, now we're in the realm of
the aesthetic and and uh we're no longer like this is no longer a question of the cognitive and this is
to me what makes and made Nietzsche and continues to make Nietzsche for many like dismissible as a
thinker is because like, oh well, this is about sensation, experience, feeling, uh, it's not about
the sort of rigorous, um, I don't know, cognitive, mental thinking activity or whatever, um, and that's
one that I struggle with because I don't want to just say ah well you have to approach this more like
a work of art as Kaufman, right? It is complete in itself. It is a work of it is a work of art, and I'm
like I don't want to call it a work of art. Like I want to call it a work of philosophy but of a of a
different kind of philosophy. Like I want it to I want to maintain its wedding, its connection to
the central activity of discursive conceptual movement let's say, um, so I I want to hang on to
that because I feel like if we shift over to art then it just becomes it's so easy to just be like
well let's just talk about your experience, like what clicked for you or what didn't quit you know
you just it just shifts the terrain away from like the question Nathaniel asked is a totally like we
can talk about that what are ways of conceptualizing the middle and what Nietzsche is after for the
middle, right? That's not a kind of aesthetic response, right? Like to me it's not it's a provocation
to to thinking, um, and that's the thing it's like trying to find for me at least trying to
find I don't know if it's a middle ground or a different ground kind of between what goes under
the name of philosophy and what goes under the name of literature or art, like something other than
Derrida has a great quote uh um I can't remember where I read it but where he says like I dream
of something other than philosophy and literature that is irreducible to either of those categories
but is not simply a rejection of those categories either, and it's like there's a lot of stuff going
on in a sentence like that but it's the same problem where it's just like I I want something
other than what looks like traditional philosophy but I don't I'm not comfortable saying it needs to be
more artistic, you know? Maybe because I I've read all the all the other figures that we've read, um
Derrida, Heidegger, they've taken Nietzsche so seriously as a thinker that I don't feel like I personally have
to defend him on that point so it's like even if this is the more artistic piece compared to
some of his more systematic works I'm like you can still treat it like a like a thoroughly conceptual
complex but I'm betting that that's the reason we don't know how to read it and teach it is that we
internalize like I I'm betting that each of us like we don't have to offer the defense of it. I I agree
with that but we don't know what to do with it yeah like we we don't know how I mean we're going to be
figuring it out because we're going to be talking about for the next you know few months, right? So
we're going to figure out and I don't think we're going to have any problem like I I don't think we're
going to have any problem the three of us are not going to have any problem talking through this
because we've already made a kind of baseline investment in Nietzsche so that's where I think
Nathaniel's right like the pedagogical question becomes a better way yeah of asking this like how do
you get how do you get someone else how do you get students and like Brad students meaning people who
have some kind some kind of investment how do you get them to engage this without looking for the
argument or the main point and not just experiencing it as a work of art you know as pithy maxims
I think one of the main problems especially with teaching is just logistical. You just don't get to
spend enough time with it and when there is like the nice thing about an argument and sort of
information in a book is that you can more or less encapsulate it in a class session or two, right?
because even though like no book can be sort of like fully right right right you know in a class
you can't at least like like students can walk away and like I have you know a version of the
argument and I can kind of like sum it up I can sort of pocket it away and I know that if I go back
it'll be sort of richer and deeper that's right I have something and what I've been thinking about
over the past few minutes is just that this is a book that you can the only responses you can have
to or to dismiss it or to live in it the only sort of affirmative response is to and and this is to me
The pedagogical project of this, how do you entice or seduce students and yourself to live in this book?
And that obviously has a logistical blockage, like you'd have to spend time with it, you'd have to, like
devote weeks if not like a half of a term to just living in this book. How does one live in this book?
Maybe you go out of it for a little bit and then come back to it. Well, I i feel like that, I mean, yeah.
You could try to do it sort of like holistically like that, but I haven't read the rest of it so I
don't, I don't, I can't even conceptualize what book one is about, what book two, but with the preface
which we've read, I feel like that was pretty digestible. I mean, like, especially for the preface.
The preface is not like the rest of it though, right? It's not at all like the rest, but if we're just
teaching the preface, I mean, that's like that you can get a class period out of that, no problem. I mean,
it's like there's plenty of stuff there for even undergrads that they could latch into, you know, about
like sort of like I talk about this to my students sometime. I don't really know why, but it kind of
devolves or evolves, maybe, depending on your preference, into like motivational speaking or
like self-help kind of stuff because like they're in a very, they're in a very strange era of their
life where like they feel like adults but basically you're not, like, right? You're still, you're struggling
to kind of um emerge as a human being and there's going to be several lives that you've lived by the
time you're my age. Even like I've lived, you know, there's been like two or three lives between 18 and 28.
And I feel like there's a lot of stuff in here in that preface preface that points to the value
of that movement through through those different eras and how you kind of manage that, how you can
uh sort of learn through your suffering not just in the cliched way but like, um, actually emerge
as a different person. Um, so I feel like if we're just going with the preface, like it is kind of like
a lot of people could key into to those moments, but how would how would you feel if instead
of the preface you like okay you've got to show up now and teach the prelude in of poems like there
there's your task. I'd have some trouble with the poems I think, yeah. But one thing I do with and I
think I've talked about it on this podcast before but what I often do in my first year courses with
things like Foucault's panopticism and and stuff like that is you know where I know that they're the
argument is too complex for them I even if I like laid it out point by point it would take they wouldn't
get it and it'd be pointless to do it and more importantly that would then rely on me telling
them what's going on and so what I do instead is have and I try to balance between this just being
about subjective aesthetic experience and and like I try to turn it into a a thoughtful uh rigorous
process of like what we start with the emotive what frustrated what confused you what jumped out
to you what didn't seem to play by the rules and then we read that in class and then we sort of
develop an account of the thing and then the goal is to then have someone else like that made me think
of this other passage and we go to that other passage and we start to think about the relationships
between the two passages that we've talked about and that takes us to another passage and that that
just kind of movement of trying to read one passage in relationship to another or see how like reading
one idea sort of now suddenly opens up another one and then i was just to circle back to it that i um
that tends to work and when i did that in the history of of rhetoric course with Heraclitus because I
didn't know what to do with Heraclitus is same kind of thing right? Yeah, and I thought like I thought
I thought exactly and I intentionally assigned it with something else because I thought we're going
to talk about that something else and we'll have about 15 minutes of Heraclitus at most. We talked
the entire class about Heraclitus and nothing on whatever the other thing was. It might even have been
the Gorgias um or not the Gorgias the um uh the encomium of helen and I was like not interested
in the encomium Helen I just want to talk about Heraclitus the entire time and it was just that
movement bounce from one to the other to the other and it's like by the time you come back around to
the same fragment on the second or the third try it's amazing how different it becomes. It's amazing
how suddenly like words or phrases that seem to just be like pithy or seem to just be sort of
iconic classic for no good reason suddenly like no they're precise they're they're doing something
interesting and some kind of network is emerging between all of these things. I think that's how I
would approach these rhymes and that's probably how it'll approach the aphorisms as well.
Um, you know what I'd like to try with this book.
I mean, so for me, I've spent by far the most time with Books Three and Three, Four and Five, you know, um, not
really as much sort of attentively with with One and Two. I would like to try, I mean, if this is a bad
idea, I'm just thinking through this, so it's not like a plan at all. It's just an idea I was thinking
like, okay, so for next time we could do Book One, um, and it's like 40 pages or something, 45 pages, and
that's a fair amount, but it's not too much. But I was like, well, we could divide that in two because
then it would force us to talk about like a limited amount of stuff. But then I was like, why don't we
just say this: let's commit two weeks to Book One and like for so for next time we're going to read all
of Book One, and then for the time after we're also going to reread all of Book One, like we're just going
to do Book One so we can we can talk about the end. So we'll have the whole Book One done next time, and
we can jump around however we jump around, and then we'll do it again, like in other words redo the
exact same thing. And it's stuff that I, like I said, it's not stuff that I'm super familiar, you know, as
familiar with as the as the stuff that we get later, so I don't have a line at all. Yeah, um, we're talking
we're talking Nietzsche here. Let's let's ruminate, let's become cows. Yeah, I I like that. I I've wanted
to do that so so many times in my grad classes, of like we you guys read and we just taught signature
then context now read it again and let's do it again next week, you know. But yeah, there's just
you got 14 weeks, like you just can't give up that much time. But we don't just think about
how dominant the the underlying current some commitment to progressivism or progress or like
you know, if you don't get through a certain amount of content, if you're not if you read 10 pages and you
don't get then to to page 11, you've somehow failed, or you're like, there's just as much movement
just as much value to sitting with these pages, you know. I mean, I think there's like the fear of some
kind of laziness that they're not going to read it as closely, or they've already gotten, or if they
didn't they should just because it's difficult and right that's right, like to actually practice
that recursive approach is, you know, I don't think just valuable but also like I think exposes a
certain underlying commitment to the the deity of progress. Well, it's also, I'm sure you guys have
noticed this, reading to teach or reading for whatever situation, like each reading does produce
different thoughts regardless. I mean, it's like, and it's also kind of based on your temperament as well,
like you could be curious one day and really kind of getting into the nitty-gritty and writing notes on the
side, you could be sort of, you know, tired and just sort of feeling shitty one day and you're kind of just
trying to get through it, so I find like yeah, like sometimes I read something and it's it feels like
I'm reading something completely different and it's the same text, right? And it's kind of all the time, and
that's things I've written I feel that way about. Yeah, points to your context thing as well, right? I mean
like you're saying, like you can't strip context from content at all. Like you'd think this is
it's not even it's not even external. I mean, that's the claim that I want to make is context is not
external, you know, it is imminent too, right? It's not con no, I'm going to read panopticism for probably
like the 20th, 30th time next week, and it's going to be different. It's going to be always new. Maybe at
some point, maybe I feel like your 70th time you're like that feels like kind of like the 69th time, but
here's how we here's kind of a close. Yeah, yeah, here's here's how we understand that though, we we
understand that that happens, like that's not a you know, we're not calling attention to some novel
phenomena, but we understand it this way, which is the text remains the same, the meanings and associations
that we bring to them or take from them is is what changes and so we still maintain this notion of a
sort of static or stationary unity, and the deviation again is kind of secondary in relationship to it
and that's the thing that i i want to try to really problematize to say that that deviation is internal
to like it's not even the same like the words aren't the same words, right? Yeah, it's relational
so it's if it's really relational then that whole mechanical reproduction thing of Benjamin is like
nothing to worry about, like nothing to worry about because because in order to make the that typical
claim that the text remains the same as just the subjective experience of the thing that changes
which in pretty much anyone would buy that would suggest that the words are inscribed in the text and
have some kind of there and they are yeah and they contain something, right? But if you see them
if you see them as marks which are nothing more like they are just differential markers, right? Not containers
of things. They are differentials. Well, in that that first version where interpretation is secondary
that's that's under a whole sort of like not hierarchy but like uh a telos of understanding and
misunderstanding so it's like you are failing to understand a stable text in a variety of ways because of your
basically subjective aporia or whatever. So it's like the the other version which maybe Nietzsche would
say, and that you're saying, John, is that that relation between the subject and text is constitutively
relational to the point where there is no fidelity to right right yeah you see the other i mean the other
way like the one a to the one that you just said would be like what makes Nietzsche such a great thinker or
what makes Shakespeare such a great writer is that he's imbued these words with you know multiple
possible significations that what that's what makes them extraordinary so there's either there's two
places that you can look at for the source of the plenitude the author's greatness or the reader's
idiosyncrasy right like those are the places but but you're right what neither of those think of is
like you know what if these are relationally constituted what if they really are just relationally
constituted um then it's you don't have to locate it in one place or the other you know that that that
con is no longer with it's no longer outside it's no longer external it's just i mean at that point
that you're like it's such a problematic distinction between text and context that that the distinction
even exists right and so that there is no just a text and then we talk about the situation in which
that text emers it's not just like there's the Serena Williams thing and then there is the situation
surrounding Serena Williams there is that's what Serena Williams is or and this is i think quite
Nietzschean like the Nietzschean perspectival it's like no there are many Serena Williams i you know
Williams is or there i mean certainly there are many Nietzsches right like well just think again what
that would do to a notion of of progressivism is that you know the idea is like you know you're
you're 70th reading you understand it better than the 69th reading because there's some sort of
you're you're getting some fuller understanding of the thing but if there's no thing there if it is
a terrain of differential markers if it is nothing more than yeah like i i don't i don't
i don't uh um get Nietzsche I dive into Nietzsche and to be provoked to thinking I think I think of the
the image that keeps recurring to me in in that regard as the the marks as differential relations
there was like years ago probably 15 years ago i played a video game and i'm not going to remember
it but like either a guy is running along or a ball is running along and there are like
treads on the path that can shoot you off sideways or shoot you off at an angle or shoot you off if
you hit these treads right like uh and that's how I think think of that in terms of the marks of
language like that's what you're doing like we're encountering and it's it's shooting you off and
this like these are the marks that you're encountering are these different treads and
you don't know until you step on them which which way you're going to shoot um and it can lead you
to your doubt in the case of the game it can lead you to your death or it can push you to the end of
the level and you can succeed or whatever um but I think of it that way like it's that image just kept
occurring to me it's yeah because then that would it would have nothing to do with the genius of the
author and it had nothing to do with the subjective experience of the of the person it would really
be the relationship between the text and the reader and maybe the author um it's just where does this
thing shoot you and how and they're just going to shoot you off in ways that the author could have
never even forget about intended even knowing were possible well I mean Plato I mean 2000 years later
we're still writing about Plato yeah I don't think Hegel would have predicted that I would uh use an
example from an anime Dragon Ball Z to kind of point out how absolute spirit works that's not something he
was like fully cognizant that would happen but Hegel was arrogant pretty confident that somebody was
going to be he thought yeah he thought about it it was in the back of his mind somewhere there it's
like yeah I think I I think I know how this is going to play out
so you